brothers and sisters let me tell you
guys about halal investment oh no you're
saying brother ali not these halal
investment promises i'm gonna get this
and that no no no no listen to me very
carefully a halal investment that will
give you up to 700 times that's correct
let me repeat that
700 times in profit for each dollar you
invest
we're establishing a masjid with a dawah
and community center and if you donate
for this noble cause
allah will give you up to 700 times more
in return on the day of judgment
the example of those who spend their
wealth in the way of allah is like a
seed of grain which grows seven spikes
in each spike is a hundred grains
multiplies his reward for whom he wills
[Music]
and allah is all encompassing and
all-knowing
this means that in the hereafter you
will not only get your donation back yep
that's correct but you will inshallah
have it multiplied up to 700 times and
in addition you will get the reward for
every salah that is prayed in this
masjid
5 times a day 365
days a year every yuma that is attended
by hundreds or thousands of people
imagine all those kids
future generation brothers and sisters
learning and memorizing the quran
every single person who breaks their
fast in ramadan in the masjid
you get a share in that reward coming
straight to your scale of good deeds
on a day when our deeds will be counted
just imagine having all those prayers of
all those people on your side brothers
and sisters please help us build this
masjid because without your support we
cannot do it
click the button in this video and
secure your part of the reward insha
allah why don't you maximize your
rewards by sharing this video it's
absolutely free and get the reward for
every single people that donate because
of your share
[Music]